The Joe Rogan experience,
you know?
Yeah.
That fight was a very unexpected,
the way Paul deal decided to take him down.
I was like,
I was pretty stunned.
Yeah.
I didn't think we were going to see that.
Let me Paul Daley.
So dangerous is fucking left.
Hook is one of the best in all of the business left hand period.
Anyway,
throws it.
Both of them knew what they were going up against,
so like Yup.
Even behind the shit talk they do like,
yeah.
It was a tough fight for both of them.
It was,
but it was interesting to me watching page use is distance and that crazy karate
point style and that,
you know,
he had to,
he had a really look out for that stuff.
I mean he had a head of make sure that he wasn't getting dinged by that stuff.
Yeah.
When he's coming in with like his venom throws all this wild stuff,
like almost like a fencer like dives in on you and pops you and you could tell
Paul Daley was like really having a hard time,
like finding that range.
Yeah.
It's,
it's harder to,
to fight against guys that are long and know how to use your body like
athletically.
Is He fighting Douglas Lema?
Next is.
That's what's happening over in Beltour.
I remember seeing that Douglas Lema had a fight,
but I don't remember who the opponent was.
Who's Michael Van and Paige fighting.
Find out that he's a spectacular though,
man.
Right.
He that he landed on Cyborg was holy shit.
He caved the man's head end goal.
We've never seen that.
I've never seen Fraser.
Just insane.
Like you got hit with a media.
Imagine the pain.
Imagine man.
And he was hanging up.
The headaches are bad like four months.
He's like,
I'll be fighting,
getting four months.
And they were like,
Bro.
Yeah,
I met that guy in Brazil.
It's tough,
man.
Yeah,
he's tough.
He's been around me.
That's why when you see a guy like that cover his face and then fall down like
that.
Oh,
it is Chandler versus pitbull.
Uh,
Lima versus MVP.
That's it.
Tagless Lima's no,
jail.
11th.
He's no joke.
That's a dangerous man.
Lima,
the Opportunity Ed.
He's a fucking enormous welterweight to Lima is easy.
I've never seen him in first is a big frame for one seven woo cuts a lot of
weight.
But he's so powerful when he gets in there.
Dangerous fucking striker.
Lemas he's for real.
That to me is as interesting if not more interesting.
The Paul daily fight.
I want to see what happens.
Yeah.
His Lima is a little different.
Like he's not,
he's not gonna trash talk a lot.
Like he knows he's dangerous guide.
Yeah.
So there's Michael.
It's going to be a good one.
That's a real good one for sure.
Yeah.
Well fights like that really legitimize belter because these are fights that
they could be easily be a main event in the UFC.
Yeah.
Talent wise,
you know,
unquestionably that fight.
Whew.
Then and Paige is,
he's a real fucking hard pill to swallow,
man.
Figure that guy out.
Who the fuck can you bring in a train that can move like him?
No one you can try but you're not,
he doesn't even know how he's going to move.
You know?
I think that guy just puts out music and just whatever happens,
happens.
Yeah.
That's why this fight is so interesting because Lima is like way more like a,
has a,
just a rock solid traditional stance,
you know,
he moves real well.
Devastating power.
That's going to be a really good fight.
Where does Lima trade,
do you know?
It's a good question.
Where's Douglas Lema train?
Um,
Jamie's going to find that out for us.
Yeah.
I'm very happy that there's a bunch of good organizations like,
like one and you know like the Pfl now and Bella Tor.
It's great that fighters have options.
Super good.
Yeah,
just it
a lot of times too.
Like I like to just watch whatever's going on.
You never know who you're going to come across.
Where is that?
Where is that American top tapes somewhere.
Is it?
It's terrifying.
Nasty combinations,
man.
He's got ruthless leg kicks to man att where?
Which one?
There's a bunch of those.
Right?
On top teams.
You might be Att Florida,
I dunno.
Is He didn't look like the Florida law,
but a t.
T how many atts are there?
I have no idea.
Is there a bunch I should know that I think I've only heard of training two or
three.
Who?
Cat Fight Club?
I guess Thailand.
Oh,
really?
In this article right here though,
just came out,
uh,
yesterday.
Who?
Bootcamp fight club.
Maybe saw your fight.
It's like,
fuck it.
I'm going to Thailand to bring everybody.
Everybody come.
Joe,
your company Pooh cat fight.
Huh?
Wow.
[inaudible].